la situation des mineurs non accompagnés
nous faisons face à des mouvements de
population que la situation géopolitique
autour de nous n'est pas de nature à
ralentir dans un avenir proche des
véritables filières se sont mises en
place
parfois alimentés par des trafics le
mouvement concerne et jusqu'ici quelques
points bien identifiée du territoire
l'ile-de-france la frontière italienne
la côte d'opale la région lyonnaise et
la solidarité nationale nous avait
conduits à le répartir sur tous les
départements de mobilisant les
ressources locales mais nous constatons
vous constatez et vous êtes nombreux à
le dire
depuis quelques mois un phénomène plus
massif est plus diffus il est plus
massif parce qu'il s'accélère et il est
plus diffus parce qu'il cause concerne
un nombre croissant de département pour
bientôt les concernés tous vous l'avez
dit de façon très directe cette
situation n'est pas tenable
vous êtes où vous vous sentez dépassés
par ce mécanisme exceptionnel est
incroyablement lourd sur le plan
budgétaire
je sais que vous êtes pleinement
soucieux d'assumer le rôle de protection
de l'enfance en danger et à ce titre
d'accompagner les mineurs
non-accompagnés pour sa part
conformément aux engagements du
président la république
l'état assumera l'évaluation et
l'hébergement d'urgence des personnes se
déclarant mineurs entrant dans le
dispositif jusqu'à ce que leurs
minorités soient confirmés cet accueil
d'urgence et cette capacité à dire si
oui ou non nous sommes en phase de
mineurs ou de majeur doit relever de la
responsabilité de l'état et c'est un
engagement du président de la république
je le confirme
devant vous ce matin c'est le rôle de
l'état d'accueillir dignement une
personne étrangère sur notre territoire
de lui assurer la protection
correspondant à son statut de s'assurer
que les titres qu'elles présentent sont
authentiques de déterminer enfin son âge
pour savoir à quoi le cas échéant elle a
droit
il va donc falloir mettre en place des
dispositifs d'accueil et un processus de
prise en charge spécifique adapté les
dispositions législatives clarifier la
question des coûts
les groupes de travail se réunissent
déjà et je sais gérard collomb nicole
belloubet et agnès buzyn mobiliser sur
cette question
pour mettre toutes les chances de côté
je vous propose d'engager une mission
d'expertisé conjointe composée à la fois
de représentants des corps d'inspection
d'état et de cadres supérieurs des
conseils départementaux qui connaissent
ces sujets qui ont eu à les gérer cette
mission paritaire dans l'esprit initial
de la conférence nationale des
territoires pourrait rendre ses
conclusions très vite d'ici la fin de
l'année pour que nous puissions dès
l'année 2018 prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent en la matière en termes de
finances et d'organisation et pour
montrer notre volonté d'agir en ce sens
et comme je crois à la preuve par les
faits le projet de loi de finances pour
2010 8 prévoit des crédits
supplémentaires pour accompagner la
hausse du nombre de mineurs concernés et
pour prendre en charge à titre
exceptionnel une partie des surcoûts de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance liée à la
hausse du nombre de mineurs
non-accompagnés accueillis dans les
départements et dans tous les
départements cette année au total 132
millions d'euros sont prévus en 2018